Mr Burrell thank you very much for
speaking to us at Deutsche Valley I
wanted to start with Ukraine we've seen
that Russia has returned to the
initiative to get the grain out of
Ukraine through the Black Sea but the
deal itself is about to expire how
positive are you that Russia will be
willing to renew this deal and then keep
this agreement going
you never know
but there is no excuse
Russia cannot say that
he's not going to go to the deal again
because there are obstacles
from European sanctions the European
sanctions are not targeting food and
fertilizers experts
we have clarified this deal we'll
continue doing that but Russia has no
excuses and no reasons you know every
day that the grain from Ukraine is being
blocked you can count it on the number
of people suffering from Hunger
20 million tons of grain we have Block
in Ukraine so it's a good news that
Russia goes back to the deal
they have never should never abandoned
it
let's hope that we'll continue opening
the door for the Ukrainian grain go to
fit the world
we're going towards winter and we see
Russia bombing civilian infrastructure
in Ukraine including electricity
networks water networks it's going to be
a different difficult winter for Ukraine
our EU countries also G7 countries doing
enough at the moment to support Ukraine
and keep supporting Ukraine enough
what is enough
Russia is destroying a country
the Russian army is unable to conquer it
the ukrainians are resisting and
rejecting The Invader
but they are trying to destroy it and
that's what they are doing you can
destroy your country at hundreds of
kilometers far away
they are destroying mainly the
electricity system they want to put
ukrainians into the darkness in the call
during the winter and I hope also they
wait also for us
European people
to be weakened
and in the winter
not to be so ready to support ukrainians
and we have to be ready to support
ukrainians they are bearing the worst
part of this story
we have to support them millions of
ukrainians right now they don't have
access to electricity
and when the winter will be stronger and
the temperature will go in down
they want to push these people out of
Ukraine
escaping to Europe
so we have to support them
providing
capacity to mend the electricity system
and mainly arms to defend
anti-radians anti-alien weapons
to shut down the drones before the Drone
explodes
over their heads over their houses over
there
power stations this is our mortal Duty
you know this is the moral duty of the
Europeans
how much do you think European countries
are ready and willing to take possibly
new and more Ukrainian refugees who
might leave the country now that the
conditions there in Winter become
increasingly difficult I cannot put a
figure now we are hosting about four
million ukrainians refugees
10 Millions Escape many of them came
back to Ukraine
and certainly you can imagine
you don't have heating you have light
you have electricity to have water what
would you do you will live
and that's what Russia is doing the same
thing that Putin is doing trying to
block
to block
the grain from Ukraine less grain in
Africa means more migration
they are trying to create political
instability and they are trying to
create migration waves because they know
that Europeans are very sensitive to
migration so we have to continue
supporting Ukraine and we have to make
the deal working grain out
electricity in that's what we have to do
now on China you've said recently that
European countries should make an effort
to see China as a competitor more than
as a partner and to move away from
economic dependency from China but now
German Chancellor Schultz is on his way
to China right now with a full
delegation of Business Leaders how do
you see this trip from Schultz is it
going in the wrong direction and no look
China is Japan no doubt about it it's
also competitor an economic competitor
and is a political rival because their
political system is a completely
different one from us we are democracy
multi-party competition
and they are a single party they work in
a different way so we are rival we are
competitors and we are Partners but
Germany is very much important the
export to China and the investment in
China and we are not looking for
decoupling the economy of China with our
economies because it would be and
everybody will be losing so I understand
perfectly that Germany and All European
countries in different degrees have an
economic interest and continue
partnering with with China it doesn't
mean that we are not Vigilant that we
are worried about a lot of things but I
understand perfectly that Europe is not
trying to decouple economically with
China
is there a risk that European countries
will make the same mistake that they
made with Russia with China
well we are not we don't import a 40 of
our gas from China
certainly our energy dependency and
Russia was too much
but it's no longer too much
before the war
our cash dependency from Russia was 40
percent of our Imports 40 almost half of
our inputs now it's about seven percent
in a few months we have been able to
reduce our energy dependency from Russia
from 40 to 7 it's a lot incredible
and we will be reducing it until
Vanishing completely our dependence it
was too high now we are correcting this
dependency
one last question on Iran are we going
to see a new package of sanctions coming
against Iran in in the next few weeks
we have just approved one
we have just approved one and yesterday
I had a conversation with the firanga
first minister of Iran and I insisted
that Europe is United before in front of
the what's happening there and we I told
him that we are very much worried by the
Crackdown of the demonstrators by the
situation especially of the women's
and that the European Union Stand United
behind the sanctions that we have been
taken
which doesn't prevent us of trying to
continue discussing about the nuclear
deal with Iran
because it's the only way that we can be
sure that they done doesn't doesn't
become a nuclear power
Mr Burrell thank you very much thank you